[Music]
[Music]
how can we state that and Detroit Sun
lion don't leave the Serengeti I beside
he's gonna be our year I think Gilly you
realize you don't worse father ever I'm
not gonna let you ruin your life Don no
drugs in the house
everything's fine fine let her talk stay
out of it put some clothes on will ya
we're going for custard y'all know who
my dad is right yeah I know what I saw
yeah I know your broke ass dead what you
said your name was Bret hey white boy
Rick
yes balls coming here like you did you
should come out a skater Oh sometime but
not like this
like you're out the Kmart or something
you good Rick you want to move wait you
come to me my dad finds this he'll kick
my ass just make sure he doesn't find it
then break it down the down rocks
get yourself a pool and I'll float it
before long people among the gym
you're gonna get into deep man their
regular challenge
eight pounds 14 ounces such a way you
were born first time I looked in your
eyes I mean you have a big [ __ ] when
your life was gonna be bigger than mine
look at this dad look how we're living
let's hustle big I know the players and
I know the game
hey come on dad I can do this we can do
this we can fix our lives and be a
family again
what do you say
ask yourself this would you believe a
fifteen-year-old kid was working for the
federal government but it was what you
all got him
[Music]
you